[Music]
episode 4 the mandalorian second season
chapter 12 the siege is once again
stuffed with fun easter eggs for fans to
find
here are some of the more notable nods
to star wars lore you may have missed
in the opening moments of the siege
mando and the child make way to navarro
so the razer crest can receive some
much-needed repairs before the big trip
to corvus
navarro has undergone some serious
changes since the last time mando was
here but the seedier criminal element to
get navarro its reputation remain
festering in the shadows
one such example is the small band of
aqualish thieves who took up residence
in the armor's former forge
navarro's new marshal kara dune makes
quick work of the aqualish a recurring
species in the star wars universe
familiar to fans of a new hope
especially
one particularly short tempered aqualish
named ponda baba famously tried to pick
a fight with luke skywalker in the most
eisley cantina before obi-wan intervened
grief karga and kara dune insist that
mando leave the child at the newly
established school on navarro
but not before passing a statue of ig-11
the assassin droid
who sacrificed itself for our heroes in
season one at the school which was a
cantina when we last saw in the season
one finale
i'm surprised to see this place is still
standing the child gets a chance to
learn about the current geographic
makeup of the galaxy
or at least he would if he wasn't
fixated on those macaron-like turquoise
cookies
at any rate during the lesson the
protocol droid instructor name-dropped
some relevant locations in the star wars
universe the most notable detail the
droid teacher touches on
is that the new republic capital is
shifted from the iconic locale of
coruscant to chandrala
the birthplace of mon mothma and ben
solo aka kylo ren
in the same lesson the droid also points
to an important area of the galaxy
called the academy maelstrom which
hosted one of solo a star wars story's
most intense sequences
this dangerous region houses the maul
cluster the home of the beast that
nearly swallows the millennium falcon
hole during han solo and his crew's
perilous attempt to make the famed
kessel run
they of course make it in less than 12
parsecs as long as you round down
speaking of solo the red-skinned alien
who plants a tracker on the razer crest
is a mim-van zee a species first
introduced in the standalone prequel
flick
with a child presumably safe at school
and the razor crest in for a tune-up
grief mando and kara head back to
grief's office to talk business
the moment they walk in the door they're
greeted by mithril who now lives a life
of servitude to make up for getting on
grief's bad side
this is the same character mando took
the bounty on and frozen carbonite in
the mandalorians premiere episode
despite having thought some time ago
mithril complains of a very familiar
side effect that comes with prolonged
carbon freezing
grief makes sure to let mithral know he
has no qualms about sticking him back on
ice should he not follow his directions
to which the blue alien remarks that he
prefer not to and that he still can't
see out of his left eye
this refers back to return of the jedi
in which han solo's release from
carbonite established the existence of
hibernation sickness
an ailment that presents itself as
temporary blindness depending on the
length of one's imprisonment
the team wastes little time to party
navarro for the outlying imperial base
on the installation's upper level cara
mando and grief assess their situation
and review the plan while mithril stands
on
what will become their one-way ticket
off the sabotaged base a trexel marauder
this vehicle which appears to be a
variation of an imperial troop transport
has popped up in a few star wars
projects lately including star wars
rebels
but it took over four decades to get the
vehicle in live action
this particular people movers roots go
all the way back to the toy stores of
1978
where the imperial troop transport
arrived as part of kenner star wars
action figure line
so mithril's excitement at finding a
quote mint trexel marauder is likely a
nod to the vehicle's toy store origins
surprisingly the mission to rid navarro
of imperial presence goes off without a
hitch
the crew manages to make a fairly clean
getaway but not before they uncover a
disturbing secret about why the empire
is so interested in the child
by the looks of things the imperial
remnant is going all in and trying to
perfect a way to clone a force-sensitive
beam
a hologram message from dr pershing
explains the empire's dire need for the
child's blood if they are to keep this
mysterious program going
he also mentions the child's m count
likely referring to the amount of many
chlorines in his body that contribute to
his proficiency in the force
many chlorines have remained one of the
most controversial parts of the star
wars universe since their debut in the
phantom menace and fans haven't heard
them discussed in the franchise for
quite some time
so what does this all mean this
fledgling imperial cloning
program could connect the mysteriously
alive emperor palpatine and his tanks
full of snoke clones
the rise of skywalker established that
palpatine spent years biding his time on
hexagonal and rapidly decaying bodies
attempting to find the path to
immortality through cloning
the remnants of his empire could have
been hard at work trying to create a new
more powerful form for their leader
during the events of the mandalorian
considering how strong yoda and the
child species is in the force and the
length of their natural lifespan there's
no better candidate for a sith lord
who's trying to rule the galaxy for all
time with absolute power
but there's also another possibility at
the very end of the siege mop gideon
admires a whole room full of large black
stormtrooper-like figures
what are those supposed to be the audio
description on disney plus has the
answer
calling them immobilized dark troopers
dark troopers first popped up in the
1995 first person shooter game star wars
dark forces where it's implied that
they're droids
and the word immobilized does suggest
that gideon and his technician are
tending to a fleet to power down bots
but dark troopers have also been
described as cyborgs and other star wars
media meaning gideon could be preparing
exo suits for future force-sensitive
clone bodies to occupy
dark troopers also appear in the dark
empire series of comics as elite
stormtroopers who have received horse
training so this could also be the
destiny gideon has in mind for the
clones
after all if they're just droids why
wouldn't gideon have already deployed
them
perhaps he's waiting for a batch of
powerful force users to bring the suits
to life
and that's the whole point of dr
pershing's mysterious cloning project
whatever they turn out to be they're
probably bad news
mando had better be ready check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one